françois rebsamen le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous le climat politique se
couvre pour la gauche avec pour la
deuxième fois et candidat ps éliminé par
le front national lors d'une législative
partielle la tromperie cahuzac
n'explique pas tout certains
parlementaires ps réclame d'ailleurs des
messages moins anxiogène de la part du
gouvernement
vous nous direz quel est votre avis sur
le sujet françois rebsamen avec nous ce
soir jean louis prévost de notre
partenaire l' agence france-presse
et puis bien sûr perrine tarneaud de
public sénat émission proposée également
en association avec dailymotion
le ps a donc perdu ses électeurs à
villeneuve sur lot est ce que vous savez
où ils sont passés pour beaucoup dans
l'abstention
beaucoup sont découragés par l'impact de
la sphère cahuzac par le mensonge de
jérôme cahuzac et donc beaucoup sont
restés chez eux ils sont aussi ce que je
crois un patient parce que je conseille
insu sur fond de difficultés économiques
mais il faudrait vérifier cela dans
d'autres circonstances que dans cette
affaire parce que l'impact du mensonge
de jérôme cahuzac sur cette
circonscription est certain en tous les
cas pour les électeurs socialistes
n'explique pas tout non je ne simplifie
pas une ça n'explique pas tout bien sûr
vous savez quand on est au pouvoir des
moments difficiles comme à une politique
aujourd'hui juste mais les gens sont
inquiets impatients et il y à une plus
forte abstention d'une partie de
l'électorat de gauche
c'est vrai qu'on parle ne paraît pas
dans votre sanction mais en moi non je
ne pense pas je suis très inquiet de la
poussée du front national parce que
l'ump recule le ps recule beaucoup les
autres partis
n'en profite pas du tout de cette de ce
recul et seul le fn progresse en voix et
donc il ya peut-être une situation
particulière mais quand ça fait la
deuxième fois que ça se reproduit moi je
pense que on doit analyser ça
sérieusement et et ils répondent
répondre je crois que il ya beaucoup
d'éléments j'ai fait un débat houleux
enfin un forum à colloque sur la
droitisation de la société française et
donc je pense que nous devons apporter
des éléments de nature à rassurer
l'électorat de gauche
mais justement lors de ce colloque
organisé au sénat avec la fondation jean
jaurès vous aviez dit redouter une
déflagration politique aux municipales
et aux européennes
eh bien elle se profile bel et bien
cette déflagration non ce que j'ai dit
c'est que quand il y avait des défaite
idéologique ça entraînait des défaites
électorales et donc la lune
circonstances un peu particulières donc
ça mérite d'être analysée plus
profondément plus justement
mais c'est clair qu'il faut faire
attention à cette montée d'une forme de
populisme qui existe aujourd'hui et qui
est porté par le front national parce
que l'ump ferait bien d'y réfléchir
aussi à deux fois
sauf à se faire manger de l'intérieur
parce que la jonction idéologique a été
fait en 2010 avec la campagne les propos
de nicolas sarkozy et cela a continué
avec ce qu'on appelle au pardon la
droite populaire où la droite forte je
sais plus comment elle s'appelle dans
tous les cas les propos de monsieur
pelletier pour la jonction idéologique
et que le front national ça profite au
front national avant de propriété est ce
qu'une front républicain mais auquel le
ps a appelé sans hésiter ne risque pas
de renforcer marine le pen dans ses
critiques de ce qu'elle appelle lui-même
ps ce qu'elle fait pas la différence
c'est vrai qu'il faut expliquer pourquoi
nous devons faire barrage au front
national dans cette élection il est vrai
que ont raison c'est ce que je disais de
la jonction idéologique qui a été fait
il ya beaucoup d'électeurs de gauche qui
aujourd'hui ne veulent pas voter ump au
deuxième tour donc il ya là
danger et moi j'appelle fortement à à
tout faire pour que le front national ne
l'aide pas cette circonscription alors
vous parlez de jonction idéologique
entre la droite et l'extrême droite
française ça mais quand on écoute marine
le pen est bien le fustigent la
politique libérale et critique
l'austérité imposée par bruxelles
et c'est ce que dit aussi la gauche ps
oui il y a sur certains points et dans
le recentrage de marine de marine le pen
qui ont le voile et c'est ce qui la
range d'ailleurs bien de la marche à des
groupes d'extrême droite qui se
réclament ouvertement de du nazisme pour
certains et bien on a en a laissé cela
et marine le pen parle de l'europe et
les difficultés de l'europe donc il faut
que ceux qui considèrent que la
politique comme françois hollande
aujourd'hui menée en europe n'est pas
satisfaisante qu'il faut retrouver les
vols la croissance doivent se faire
entendre
bien sûr mais l'europe n'est pas
l'europe n'est pas la seule responsable
c'est pas l'europe en tant que tel c'est
les politiques ultra libérales et c'est
surtout cette politique d'austérité qui
est menée par l'union européenne et par
certains commissaires européens on vient
encore de le voir à propos de
l'exception culturelle qui construit la
france mais la france elle suit sa
propre politique simplement elle sait
qui vend le cadre du pacte de stabilité
il s'est rallié françois agostini lamy
le volet il a mis à voler croissance
vous le savez de 120 milliards d'euros
qui sont d'ailleurs pas tous mobilisés
au jour d'aujourd'hui est donc moi
j'espère que dans le prochain sommet
européen
la voie que porte françois hollande mais
qui n'est pas seul sur la croissance va
commencer à se faire entendre il n'y a
pas de fatalité au déclin du vieux
continent à propos de l'europe est ce
que vous estimez que la france est mal
payé de retour vous avez fait une
allusion à l'instant aux propos de josé
manuel barroso qui est décrit avec la
france et est réactionnaire en défendant
l'exception culturellement s'aperçoit
après coup même si une explication des
gravures au g8 entre françois hollande
et le président de la commission
européenne que cette commission
bruxelles reste quand même sur la ligne
barroso c'est à dire que tout reste
assez ouvert dans les négociations avec
les états unis
non j'ai dû lire l'heure européenne ne
voue pas mandat pour la commission pour
les chefs d'état et ça sera confirmée
pour les chefs d'état l'accord européen
vos mandats et monsieur barroso doit se
plier strictement au mandat qui lui est
confié
quant aux propos que tient monsieur
barroso ils sont inacceptables pour
notre pays et il a visé plus
généralement les artistes et cetera
l'exception culturelle française mais
même l'exception culturelle européenne
aujourd'hui puisque ça s'est étendu
c'est quelque chose que nous défendrons
d'eczéma très bien et vous estimez qu'il
est sorti de son rôle
je vais considérer bien sûr je pense que
il est sorti de son rôle de sa place il
doit respecter le mandat qui lui a été
confié est-ce que ça on vous amène être
plus sévère encore aujourd'hui pour je
ne sais pas qualifié son bilan des dix
ans oui monsieur barroso est un libéral
bon teint et il mène une politique
libérale il ne conçoit pas que la
croissance ou pas assez de la croissance
est nécessaire pour redonner des marges
au pays et en enfonçant certains pays
dans l'austérité qui s'ajoute à
l'austérité
on a des situations certaines situations
dramatiques et on ne les sort pas on ne
leur sort pas la tête de l'eau chacun
doit faire des efforts que l'on soit
clair il ya des efforts à faire pour
réduire les déficits budgétaires pour
assainir ses propres finances ou archos
et la grèce pour mettre en place un
dispositif cohérent au niveau de
l'échelle européenne de l'union
européenne sur les impôts et les
impositions avoir un cadastre etc
mais par ailleurs si en plus l'union
européenne
en tous les cas la commission leur
enfoncer la tête sous l'eau ils s'en
sortiront pas et c'est tout le monde qui
se rendaient alors vous défendre la
politique du gouvernement vous dit
qu'elle est juste mumbai et revenir dans
un instant et que notre ami jean du
prévôt de l' agence france-presse
vous connaissez vous au sénat françois
rebsamen l'étroitesse des majorités est
ce que votre homologue à l'assemblée
nationale monsieur l'euro pourrait
connaître la même expérience d'ici la
fin du quinquennat avec peut-être la
perte de la majorité absolue pour les
socialistes vous l'avez rappelé
prévert une série de défaites 8 ans fait
du client aux élections législatives
partielles et on sait une majorité
fragile ce sont des alliés plus exigeant
plus turbulents vous en avez une
expérience ici c'est vrai j'appelle
c'est pour ça que j'appelle mais par
delà le problème du groupe socialiste
qui ne se pose pas encore pour le moment
qui peut se poser de toute façon à
l'unité j'appelle au rassemblement
autour du môle du constituent les les
parlementaires socialistes autour du
parti socialiste nous devons
reconstituer cette ce rassemblement des
forces de gauche des radicaux qui sont
proches de nous d'abord comme nous
l'avons fait d'ailleurs au sénat des
écologistes et des communistes s'il le
souhaite nous devons prendre tout le
monde doit prendre conscience de la
réalité auxquels est confronté ce
gouvernement et notre pays aujourd'hui
une grande difficulté avec une poussée
du populisme voire de la démagogie et
donc je pense que c'est par le
rassemblement par l'unité de la gauche
qu on avancerait vous appelez quoi vous
aimez écologistes qui me sont au
gouvernement à un sursaut unitaire
j'appelle les socialistes à marc tessier
le parti socialiste a ainsi entamé des
discussions sérieuses de fond pour que
ce rassemblement puisse s'opérer en vue
des élections municipales par exemple
d'accord mais qu'est ce que vous
attendez des écologistes parce que c'est
eux qui sont remuant jean vincent placé
par exemple à votre homologue au sénat
qui préside le groupe des écologistes
qui réclament un changement de cap il
estime que à propos de vos commentaires
allez le commentaire du ps sur
l'élection de lot-et-garonne
il estime que vous avez perdu les
pédales je le cite leur incapacité à
analyser la situation est un aveu de
faiblesse et la preuve de leur désarroi
dites moi voilà ce que dit votre allié
mais vous connaissez jean vincent placé
et vous connaissez ces formules ont
pourrais je pourrais en bouche pour la
méchamment le renvoyer je ne le ferai
pas le résultat de
du candidat écologiste 2004 pour cent
donc c'est un problème politique qui
nous est posée aux écologistes ou
socialiste aujourd'hui nous devons
retrouver la voie du rassemblement
reprendre le dialogue et avancer
ensemble mais ça vous fait tourner et
stéphane le foll le ministre
l'agriculture hollandais comme vous un
françois rebsamen et à votre place ya
quinze jours il y l'aï quittée un sort
particulier à jean vincent placé le cas
non je le vois entrer les amarres au nom
je le vois régulièrement je discute avec
lui j'ai des relations convenables
correct voire voire amicales avec les
mais lassé de la politique dont il
s'agit on a par exemple le climat des
affaires puisque on pourrait citer
également tapis bettencourt guéant et
ses enveloppes du ministère de
l'intérieur être est ce que ce climat
est nocif à la droite comme à la gauche
de toute façon faisant le distinguo la
sphère cahuzac elle est nocive l'est est
possible d'abord au parti socialiste
parce qu'il était membre du parti
socialiste
ensuite c'est nocif de toute façon à
l'image des politiques en général
et puis ce qu'on appelle l' affaire
tapie tapis prenons-le affaire tapie non
jean sarkozy non j'allais dire guéant
parce que vous avez cités ans elle est
citée guéant
la faire tapis guéant richard enfin tous
ceux qui sur laissons la justice agir
moi je le dis pour les élus que ça leur
arrive je crois à la présomption
d'innocence
donc je la respecte on verra bien s'il
était prouvé que il ya une machination
pour verser de l'argent à tapis ce
serait une autre histoire on serait dans
un scandale d'état
pour le moment les sur la justice agir
et on verra bien
on espère justice agir mais jean pierre
raffarin vous avez remarqué qu est l
agir toute indépendance en toute
indépendance
donc elle va suivre son chemin et elle
me vire à jean-pierre affaires dénoncé
une orchestration politique il parle
d'une justice ce spectacle qui
n'auraient en fait qu'un seul but
bloquer le retour de nicolas sarkozy qui
rêve d'être un recours
mais c'est quelqu'un que j'apprécie
bhutto en général ça faire j'avais enfin
je pense qu'ils en général il ya une
parole plutôt sensée raisonnable on m'a
nist de droite voit la droite humaniste
comédie donc j'ai du respect pour lui
mais là je pense que il dérape jamais la
justice n'a été aussi indépendante
qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes pas dans la même situation
qu'avec la droite
donnons pas d'ordre dans les affaires
particulières nous ne ne m'ont pas les
procureurs et donc laissons faire la
justice
est ce que vous pensez comme fleur
pellerin qu'un système s'est mis en
place durant les années du sarkozysme
un système ce qu'il y avait du temps de
nicolas sarkozy s'est uni mais une hyper
concentration du pouvoir de tous les
pouvoirs de tous les moyens une hyper
informations du président donc beaucoup
de choses dures montées
ça c'est pas moi qui le dit et puis il
avait aussi ses affidés des personnes
qui le suivait à peu aveuglément je
pense à la lettre que madame lagarde a
pu lui envoyer
je trouve particulièrement inquiétante
vous avez lu ce fait de christine
lagarde effectivement ty et éclat sa
femme et sa dévotion au chef de notre
guide aux guides audio guide je sais des
propos que j'imagine mal tenir au parti
socialiste
le guide jeu ça d'autres peut-être que
ça ferait plaisir à françois hollande de
recevoir ce genre de courrier au
ministre
non c'est pas le c'est pas du tout le
genre non non ça me fait rire peut-être
non je pense que cela triste heurette
m'attriste allez on va maintenant parler
de la marche de l'exécutif de la ligne
politique que vous allez défendre même
si les réformes c'est les messages sont
anxiogènes selon certains parlementaires
socialistes avec donc jean-louis
provoque prévaut de l'agencé france
presse qui ne rejoint juste à après vrai
ce reportage de mounir souci françois
hollande comme jean marc ayrault vous
l'avez vu il semble avoir enrayé leur
chute dans les sondages attention à un
petit rebond pas encore l'espoir que le
plus dur est passé
+ 1 % dans la dernière enquête lh2 le
nouvel obs
idem dans le baromètre bva le parisien
depuis trois semaines françois hollande
enraye sa chute dans les sondages
une embellie principalement due à une
meilleure visibilité de sa ligne
politique
les français ont le sentiment que
françois hollande est plus clair dans ce
qu'il veut faire et plus volontaire
aussi et en même temps qu'il est plus
présent le président de la république a
multiplié avec plus ou moins de succès
les prises de paroles et les
interventions directes conférence de
presse émissions ou réaction à chaud
françois hollande s'expose à matignon le
premier ministre bénéficie aussi de ce
frémissement en partie grâce à la
diminution des couacs au sein de son
équipe et les dernières annonces les
dernières réformes les dernières les
derniers engagements de france en venant
souvent été annoncé au à travers lui on
voit bien que matignon dans
l'élaboration de la politique a repris
du poids les une offensive de la presse
qui ont rythmé la première année de
mandat sont de moins en moins
d'actualité
peut-être la fin d'un cycle mais pour
l'opposition fin de la chute ne veut pas
forcément dire remonter quand on est à
moins de et qu'on passe à - 1 c'est pas
un rebond il est sous l'eau avec un tuba
simplement l'or le tuba marche quelques
quelques semaines quelques jours mais ça
va tellement mal et les résultats aux
élections le pauvre huit élections
d'affilée 8 perdues dont quatre sans la
présence du ps au 2e tour avec 32 %
d'opinions favorables en moyenne
françois hollande repart de très bas
mais son flegme qui hérite aujourd'hui
ses adversaires pourraient payer à long
terme c'est la vie optimiste de cet
observateur il a une attitude par
rapport à sa propre popularité par
rapport aux mauvais sondages par rapport
aux mauvais papier qui est une attitude
extraordinairement zen on a le sentiment
que ça ne l'at qu'il en a conscience
qu'il ne l'occultent pas mais que ça ne
l'atteint pas tellement ce qui le touche
directement ses les mauvais indicateurs
économiques tant que la courbe du
chômage ne s'inversera pas celle de sa
popularité restera dans les profondeurs
bonsoir en question donc cette timide
embellie dont les cotes de popularité à
la fois de françois hollande les deux
jean marc ayrault pour vous qu'est-ce
qui est ce qu'elle est solide
est-ce qu'il s'agit uniquement d'un
épiphénomène ou est-ce que ça va durer
est ce qu'on ne peut pourrait rêver que
finalement le plus dur est derrière eux
ou est-ce que les difficultés vont
continuer son nom seul et les
difficultés vont continuer la situation
économique est grave et donc françois
hollande le dit lui même
tant que nous n'aurons pas retrouvé le
chemin d'un développement durable d'une
croissance améliorer l ut diminuer le
chômage
il faut pas penser une embellie par
contre une stabilisation une certaine
remontée dans les sondages que l'on
constate aujourd'hui j'en suis très
heureux correspondent à mon avis au fait
que le président de la république a
expliqué le cap qu'il a donnée il a
commencé à raconter il doit continuer il
a commencé à raconter l'histoire de
france à savoir dans quel état il a
trouvé le pays
qu'est ce qu'il a fait pendant la
première année l'an 1 qu'est ce qui va
faire pendant deuxième année où on va je
pense que ça tous les cas rassuré sur sa
capacité à faire face à la situation
économique donc d'autres d'autre part il
a mis en place un dispositif de
coordination de la majorité avec le
premier ministre qui lui même a
stabilisé les choses je crois que les
ministres aujourd'hui savent à quoi s'en
tenir
ils sont ministres de leur ministère et
évite de s'exprimer sur tout sujet à
tout moment donc les choses vont mieux
de ce côté là bas pour autant l'embellie
vous savez
le pressentait dans la situation
économique il n'y a pas de dirigeant
aujourd'hui qui connaissent une embellie
au vent c'est que françois hollande a
quand même maintenant trouver son style
qu'il a réussi à s'investir dans son
costume présidentiel au début du
quinquennat relevé reprocher un peu
d'être hésitant ne pas être encore
habité par sa fonction maintenance et y
est il le tient il tient les rênes oui
je crois que ça fait un moment
moi j'ai vu assurément un tournant à
travers la conférence de presse j'avais
déjà vu sa capacité mais moi je le
savais a décidé à travers l'opération
militaire a été lancée au mali françois
hollande c'est quelqu'un qui décide
contrairement à ce qu'on croit je pense
que les français commencent à le
comprendre mais il veut le faire
toujours avec justice et donc certaines
décisions mérite à temps de réflexion
quand il s'agit pas d'arrêter des
troupes djihadistes qui venait donc
c'est ce qui fait pour essayer d'avancer
avec le souci de la justice mais ici
c'est le cap
il l'a dit le cap qu'il avait je pense
que ça a rassuré en partie l'électorat
de gauche puisque c'est bien par lui
qu'il faut commencer
et pourtant dimanche elle a participé à
une émission à capital une émission de
principe grand public axé sur les
questions économiques et le score de
nuances de cette émission
malheureusement n'a pas été hâtée de
très très loin des records d'audience
déjà enregistré par cette émission
comment vous vous l'avez trouvé votre
avis est-ce qu'il s'agissait pas une
erreur d'aller un tel type d'émission un
peu spécialisée surtout un dimanche a
annoncé un dimanche soir alors que il y
est quand même de la concurrence sur les
grandes chaînes mais je généralise et je
partage un peu ce sentiment
vous lui avez dit non alors justement
aller n'avait pas dit
non mais je vois bien l'idée de
s'adresser à un public qui n'écoutent
pas les émissions grande émission
politique et qui aime bien cette
émission économique eu un peu sur mon
expression populaire et donc c'est
sûrement une bonne idée mais moi je
pense que le président de la république
doit continuer dans la ligne de sa
conférence de presse à dire les
orientations du pays
les grandes orientations et c'est au
premier ministre d'expliquer les
décisions critiques de françois fillon
était sévère pas ce flop de cette
interview dimanche quand il a dit ben
voilà on a la preuve que françois
hollande n'a pas de cap pas de vision
abstraite débilité je pourrais dire que
fillon qui ferait mieux de s'occuper de
ses affaires plutôt que de critiquer
aussi stupidement il ferait mieux de
faire déjà un inventaire où en es l'ump
quels sont les problèmes idéologiques
auxquels ils sont confrontés et de
redresser la tête plutôt que de penser
déjà à la présidentielle parce qu'il n'a
que ça en tête
pensez déjà à la présidentielle on en a
encore pour quatre ans et nous on a une
tâche du président de la république le
gouvernement les groupes parlementaires
savoir et c'est le pays pour en revenir
aux sondages quand on les examine de
près bon concept quand même une une
consolidation de la position de
l'exécutif à gauche surtout au parti
socialiste est en revanche quand on
examine au niveau des catégories
socioprofessionnelles on se rend compte
que les 18 25 ans qui porte quand même
l'avenir du pays
leur cote et ne sont pas là ils sont pas
là et je me sens pas la wii sont là
justement l'affection et ce sont eux qui
souffrent des premiers du chômage ça
fait alors est-ce que la promesse de
françois hollande de redresser la courbe
de l'emploi d'ici la fin d'année doit
être suffisante pour pour attirer à
nouveau c'est tous ces jeunes verts vers
le plus la politique et vert il faut
redonner au public
bien sûr il faut redonner espoir à cette
jeunesse là c'est le parti socialiste
mais ils n'ont pas plus d'attirance pour
pour l'ump ils sont à paris l'ont
beaucoup d'inquiétudes sur leur avenir
bien sûr pas tous les jeunes
heureusement mais notamment ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui sans formation qui
habitent dans les quartiers qui ont des
difficultés à être reconnue embaucher et
c'est donc tant qu'on n'aura pas
redonner confiance à nos chefs
d'entreprise à l'économie celle c'est
l'économie qu'il faut pas le faire
repartir elle repartira par la confiance
par des signes pas pas uniquement j'ai
dit un jour entrepreneur je vous aime et
donnons les preuves elles ont été faites
ça a été fait que le crédit d'impôt
il faut redonner la confiance il faut
une une stratégie sur le long terme sur
une politique de l'offre qui paiera par
la création d'emplois pour les plus
jeunes mais vous avez raison les jeunes
aujourd'hui il faut leur garantir que
leur vie elle va être comme le disait
hollande meilleure que celle de leurs
parents pour ça il faut les remettre au
travail il faut leur proposer du travail
vont partager l'avis des députés
socialistes ils sont nombreux ils se
sont réunis aujourd'hui ils disent qu'il
faut arrêter avec les messages
anxiogènes du gouvernement sur les
retraites sur les allocations familiales
alors parlons enfin des mulets des
retraites je pense que tout le monde a
conscience aujourd'hui que il ya
problème pour assurer la pérennité des
retraites à l'horizon 2020-2025 de
problème il n'est pas cette année il est
à l'horizon 2020 2025
donc il faut je crois apporter des
réponses parce que quand on attend des
réponses enlève ce côté anxiogène
il ya une conférence sociale qui va
s'ouvrir jeudi les partenaires sociaux
parce que c'est la marque de fabrique du
gouvernement héros c'est le dialogue
social
donc on va écouter ce que les
partenaires sociaux ont à dire non c'est
déjà le gouvernement où ils font des
propositions souvent dans ces réunions
par delà les grandes déclarations mais
dit il ya un instant les réformes se
font dans la justice oui mais quand on
n'aligne pas les régimes du public sur
le prix mais quand on ne touche pas aux
régimes spéciaux aux gains et qui
représentent le tiers du déficit à
l'horizon vous indiquez 2020 est-ce
qu'on peut tartiner justice bah écoutez
vous ne connaissez pas les propositions
qui seront faites le moment venu donc
aujourd'hui j'entends il faut faire si
il faut aller plus loin il faut être
il faut aller plus loin dans la réforme
nous on a posé les principes de base au
parti socialiste
avant on les maintient aujourd'hui et
donc le principe de base c'est que au
fur et à mesure de l'allongement de la
durée de la vie et bien le durée de
cotisation doit effectivement augmenté
après on verra quelles sont les
propositions des partenaires sociaux et
aux côtés de françois hollande est ce
que jean marc ayrault aussi qu'on disait
un peu
est ce qu'il a trouvé son rythme de
croisière aussi je crois moi je le
rencontre souvent je le vois je j'ai des
rainures avec lui c'est le chef du
gouvernement je crois qu il
il s'est imposé aidés par les
déclarations du président de la
république il est le chef du
gouvernement il est respecté par les
autres ministres et j'ai des réunions
avec le le polémiste et d'autres minutes
je vois comment cela se passe maintenant
sur le projet de loi qui a créé les
métropoles qui était finalement voté ici
au sénat jean marc ayrault avait mis
toute son autorité sur la création de la
métropole de marseille mais en revanche
le texte ça a connu un échec véritable
en cuisant sur paris alors est ce que
paris va finalement être la seule grande
ville de france à ne pas avoir ne pas
être métropole ce que vous avez dit
c'est exactement mot-à-mot ce que j'ai
dit est ce que d'autres ont dit aux élus
parisiens en responsabilité paris
métropole et paris petite couronne
donc je ne je pense je ne désespère pas
je pense qu'il va y avoir un sursaut et
des propositions qui seront faites pour
organiser la métropolisation proposition
de qui du gouvernement et jean marc
ayrault ou alors des mails vont être
prises par le gouvernement elles sont en
ce moment étudiée par les élus est
formulée par les élus eux mêmes c'est
mieux vous savez pour avancer quand ce
sont les élus eux mêmes qui font les
propositions est donc vraiment je vous
donne l impression avec ce sont les élus
et leur corporatisme et franchement est
bien présent tous les échelons
administratifs du pays qui empêche toute
réforme de la décentralisation regardé
sur ma mère regarder toute récente de
l'état
mais s'il faudrait forme de l'état c'est
un autre sujet mais regardez sur sur
marseille c'est le cas il a référé et
les socialistes avec
lui toute réforme a été votée ici au
sénat regarde également regarder lyon
la réforme a été adoptée la première
intervention et les élus se sont
entendus sur place c'est quand même
mieux c'est quand même mieux et là et
michel mercier et la sueur c'est mieux
quand ça se passe comme ça et là sur sur
paris métropole et bien il va y avoir
des propositions moi je n'imagine pas
qu'on sorte un texte et que seule paris
métropole les départements de la
couronne soit dans la capacité de faire
au moins ce qui a été fait pour
marseille quand même alors à côté des
ministres y aussi leurs cabinets et
aujourd'hui le journal le monde nous
apprend que beaucoup de députés
notamment des députés socialistes les
critiques fortement les accuse d'être
des technocrates accusé de la réalité
les sénateurs socialistes c'est ce qu'il
se prend est ce qu'ils pensent les
bonnes choses c'est quand même se
prévaut c'est quand même une sorte de
marronniers à vous savez les
parlementaires là ces parlementaires de
gauche
ils râlent toujours après les cabinets
ministériels pas tous il paraît qu'un
accès qui sont mieux que d'autres
je ne vous dirai pas lesquels mais c'est
quand même une habitude
il ya sûrement beaucoup de beaucoup de
technocratie
il en faut mais c'est bien quand il ya
du politique auprès des ministres alors
alors qu dépression justement il y à des
fonctionnaires qu'on racontait toujours
dans le monde à jean-louis avoir subi
des pressions dans l' affaire tapie
justement pour opter contre leur gré en
faveur de l'arbitrage ou même françois
rebsamen vous aviez été accusé par la
droite bat de vouloir un peu noyauté
l'état au début du quinquennat gournay
des accusations portées contre son mari
de répondre aujourd'hui soit cette
affaire la femme et moi les
fonctionnaires gelé je les respecte je
considère qu'il y à un certain nombre de
nominations qui ont été faites durant
ces dix années qui rompait cette grande
tradition de la fonction publique
française qui était que c'était au
mérite qu on accédait aux plus hauts
postes
or avec nicolas sarkozy surtout beaucoup
de nominations ont été faites uniquement
sur des critères politiques et c'est
cela que j'ai dénoncée celle là que je
dénonçais pour le reste
la fonction publique française je crois
qu'on peut en être fier dernière
question jean françois hollande est
toujours une carte dans sa manche c'est
le remaniement gouvernemental est ce que
vous croyez qu'il serait opportun de la
jouer d'ici d'ici l'été ou à la rentrée
écoutez c'est que ça ne dépend que du
président de la république donc c'est à
lui qu'il faut poser la question mais je
crois que si les choses continuent comme
ça dans l'ordre et en avançant bien pas
de raison de changer le gouvernement
babs et par les écologistes tout à
l'heure on n'avait pas dit que vous
critiquiez cette méthode mais écolo qui
participe au gouvernement sans le
soutenir
non ils ont voté les textes essentiels
au niveau budgétaire ce que j'appelle
tout le monde sait à faire bloc quand on
voit la montée du front national
merci jean louis frémaux un père
internautes public sénat harry met à
leur cumul oublie souffrance humaine
vous êtes candidat à votre succession
bien sûr à la mairie de dijon mais vous
veillez aussi à l'avenir du sénat de
gauche et si la réforme du mode de
scrutin des sénateurs
qui va être et beauté instamment au
sénat toujours en débat à l'heure où
nous parlons
visa a remporté une victoire sur tapis
vert c'est en tout cas l'accusation de
l'ump jérôme ramier il ya deux ans la
gauche sont parés de la forteresse
jusque-là imprenable du sénat désormais
au pouvoir pas question d'abandonner la
présidence de la haute assemblée à une
opposition qui trouverait une tribune
idéale pour s'exprimer alors à un an du
renouvellement de la moitié de
l'hémicycle
la réforme du mode de scrutin sénatorial
est une véritable provocation pour la
droite il essaye par tous moyens de
garder le sénat la vraie réponse ce sera
au moment des élections municipales
vous savez c'est pas en bricolant les
systèmes électoraux qu'on s'assure la
victoire au fait vrai sujet le vrai
sujet c'est est ce qu'on répond aux
préoccupations des français
l'argument à gauche c'est un nécessaire
rééquilibrage du poids des grandes et
moyennes communes au détriment des
petits sont pour l'instant sur
représentés et avec la mise en place de
la proportionnelle des la présence de
trois sénateurs dans un département
contre quatre actuellement c'est la
parité qui devrait progresser mais à
droite on a fait les calculs et ce
changement renforcerait la gauche
ça donne une avance de 7 à 8 sièges pour
le parti socialiste comme l'écart était
déjà de six sièges actuellement le parti
socialiste par quelques précautions pour
pouvoir garder le sénat s'appelle avec
des élections municipales en mars
prochain qui fourniront l'immense
majorité des grands électeurs qui votent
pour les sénatoriales
difficile de faire de tels pronostics
encore plus en sachant que ces élections
intermédiaires sont souvent très
défavorables au pouvoir en place je
crois qu'il ne faut jamais faire de
pronostics sur les conséquences d'une
réforme électorale
l'expérience montre que dans un certain
nombre de cas une réforme électorale que
ce soit au sénat ou à l'assemblée
nationale d'ailleurs se retourne contre
ses auteurs effectivement aujourd'hui la
plupart des grandes villes sont à gauche
mais ça n'a pas toujours été le cas et
ça ne sera certainement pas toujours le
cas
les calculettes devons donc être
ressorti en mars 2014
après l'élection des conseils municipaux
une chose est pour l'instant certaines
la majorité n'aura que 82 sièges en jeu
contre 96 pour le centre est là
en modifiant à la marge le mode
d'élection la gauche est ainsi peut-être
assuré un matelas suffisant pour
conserver sa majorité l'an prochain avec
le renouvellement par moitié va faire
nos petits une petit calcul ensemble
jean claude gaudin il a même été plus
sévère dans l'hémicycle lors la
discussion générale sur ce projet de loi
il a dit vous participiez à
l'équarrissage du sénat alors est ce que
la gauche est en train de voter un texte
à sa main pour gagner et pour garder sa
majorité en 2014
le texte que nous votons nous l'avions
déjà votée en 2000 et donc il s'est
appliqué en 2001 et la proportionnelle
sur l'année passionnant rien moins beau
moins trois sénateurs
c'est le sénateur donc c'est une
constante pour nous nous pensons que
pour avoir un sénat qui représente tout
à la fois le monde rural et qu'il leur
présente bien tant mieux c'est ce qu'il
faut et puis la représentation
équilibrée du monde urbain
nous pensons qu'il faut la
proportionnelle département à trois
sénateurs c'est ce que nous avions fait
en 2000 la droite a supprimé la droite
la supprimer je suis je suis pas
forcément en faux par rapport à ce que
j'ai entendu non pas de monsieur gaudin
mais de l'analyste
vous savez c'est pas chaque majorité
finalement tricote un peu ce scrutin je
suis vous savez parce que ils ont créé
deux sièges de la majorité
ils ont créé deux sièges de sénateurs ça
s'est toujours fait pour des petites
îles où il ya très peu de grands
électeurs il ya donc un sénateur de
saint barthélémy et un sénateur de saint
martin s'était pas innocent ce sont deux
sénateurs ump
bon voila nous on a eu un principe la
proportionnellement département à 3 on
l'avait mis ils l'ont supprimé on leur
met bourreau temps avec leur scrutin tel
qu'ils le voulaient ils ont perdu le
sénat c'est pas dit qu'on veut gagner
avec celui là c'est parce que nous on
est con sur la calculette on a vu jean
claude gaudin dans le temps le sujet qui
dit qu'avec ce mode de scrutin tels que
si le texte est voté ce soir au sénat
vous devriez gagner entre 7 et 20 sièges
de sénateur est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça
j'ai dit c'est plus là il est dans
l'explication politique je lui ai
répondu au sénat le débat politique mais
la vérité c'est que aujourd'hui personne
ne peut faire de pronostics sur les
élections sénatoriales pour une raison
bien simple c'est que ce sont les
élections municipales qui vont
déterminer le corps électoral et de ces
élections municipales on pourra dès
lendemain avoir une projection à
tendance on saura ce qui se passe c'est
pas la même chose si la droite perd une
grande ville où la gauche par des
grandes villes des villes moyennes
non mais je veux pas prendre le
département je stigmatise personne la
ville de dijon
oui si ce qui est passablement d'elle
c'est possible si on perd dijon
extrêmement difficile d'avoir un
sénateur
demain à fortiori 2 en 1 à 2 aujourd'hui
donc si on gagne les villans peur
d'avoir deux si on en perd on peut en
avoir qu'un psy op retourne alors à 0
donc le résultat de la victoire au sénat
qui a été retardée par le mode de
scrutin qui avait mis en place la droite
ça a été le résultat d'une longue
progression d'une lente progression des
socialistes dans les villes les
départements et dans les régions
donc on remet en jeu les élections
municipales l'année prochaine elles
auront des conséquences sur le sénat
toujours est il que ce scrutin reste
complètement incompréhensible pour le
commun des mortels mais démocratique non
je n'ai juste pas n'avait pas dès que le
sénat était le mode d'élection a vu avec
le mode d'élection qui menace car il ne
permet pour le citoyen mais oui mais
c'est une
c'est une réforme qui a voulu le pr
général de gaulle c'est dans la
constitution on est dans une république
by km le mic à meyrals donc on a deux
chambres donc à partir du vandale mika
mais rythme on a sénat il n'est pas élu
comme les députés on n'est pas élu comme
les députés et on est élu par des grands
électeurs c'est à dire par des élus et
donc après le ciment essentiel mais les
gains sont plus nombreux donc des
apparatchiks qui sont un peu plus envoyé
à dijon ont choisi pour compléter notre
corps électoral mais qui représentent un
minimum on choisit des citoyens et donc
ce sont des citoyens qui vient de voter
la moralisation de la vie publique
maintenant la partielle 2009 de
villeneuve sur lot a relancé le débat
chez certains parlementaires de votre
majorité sur une transparence un peu le
plus importante que la version édulcorée
qui est présenté devant les députés
cette semaine est ce que vous vous êtes
favorable à certains un moment enfin
vers la publication des patrimoines des
parlementaires c'est une bonne question
moi je vais reprendre le texte je vais
voir ce qui revient de l'assemblée on va
voir moi j'ai senti moi je sens mon
sentiment c'est que les socialistes ils
ont le chic pour faire apparaître une
grande avancée peut-être un des des
systèmes qui va être mis en place de
transparence les meilleurs d'europe
comme une petite chose alors que c'est
une des grandes déclarations notamment
des présents à la république à l'elysée
ce souhait puis le sentiment
effectivement doute un certain recul du
gouvernement devant la pression des
parlementaires le président de la
république qui donne une orientation il
veut de la transparence
ils veulent à transférer signée par cinq
régions socialistes
les barons socialistes route qui s'il ya
un parlement et le parlement il légifère
librement il tient compte des grandes
orientations du président nous ne
voulons pas confondre voyeurisme et
transparence nous beaucoup d'élus ne
voyait pas la raison ne voulait pas être
stigmatisés par la sphère cahuzac qui
considèrent ils veulent qu'il y ait un
contrôle réel efficace
ils veulent que le citoyen puisse être
formé je le dis pourront aller consulter
dans les préfectures le patrimoine de
tous leurs élus il ya une interdiction
de publication
parce que lui il faut un peu de décence
sur la vie privée mais pour le reste il
ya une anomalie qui est constaté j'aime
bien le 10
le citoyen peut saisir la haute autorité
et la faire une part en justice donc
vous voyez ces avancées ne sera pas le
voyeurisme à la baisse est ici parce que
le voyeurisme reçu le voyait le voyons
soit le voyeurisme dans le voyeurisme
c'est de répandre sur la place publique
tout ce qui concerne ligoté départ de
vie privée on va aller consulter en
préfecture à la déclarant un patrimoine
d'un élu et la tweet et alors ça serait
un peu oui enfin je cède à côté de vous
on verra ce qui se passera avec internet
et compagnie mais compliqué que ça met
donc une grande avancée une grande
avancée sur la transparence qui va nous
fait qui va faire de la france un des
pays les plus en avance en matière de
transparence de ces deux grandes
avancées grandes avancées je sais pas ce
que je trouve quand même que la classe
politique donnent le sentiment de se
protéger elle même
finalement il ne va pas y avoir dix que
les journalistes qui ne veut pas par
exemple y avoir de limitation entre le
cumul d'un mandat parlementaire et d'une
profession extérieurs notamment on n'a
pas beaucoup parlé des avocats il va pas
y avoir non plus de plafonnement des
rémunérations quand un parlementaire
exercent une activité extérieure réservé
aux amis seuls écologistes alors l'année
ils sont tombés dedans moi quand ils ont
vu la réforme en finale et avait produit
en finalement ont fait le reste avec un
horaire c'est pour moi une grande
avancée je voudrais leur dire ici c'est
une grande avancée et y aura des
amendements on verra ce qui va venir est
ce qu'on va faire nous on sénat moi je
suis favorable à l'orientation du
président de la république à
transparence de la vie publique des élus
et vous savez je ne confonds pas cette
forme de voyeurisme avec la transparence
l'attention c'est tout le monde puisse
être informée et consultée
voilà très bien menu danse pour la
session extraordinaire du parlement qui
va commencer le 1er juillet jusqu'au 26
juillet en revanche le gouvernement a
demandé aux parlementaires de rentrer à
partir du 3 septembre les députés
notamment la majorité ont refusé ils
préfèrent le 9 septembre cinq semaines
de vacances ça suffisait pas oui le
travail que l'on fait là vous savez le 3
septembre c'est la rentrée scolaire
or cette rentrée scolaire elle a quelque
chose d'extraordinaire c'est qu'elle est
faite avec les nouvelles conditions que
la gauche a fait
mis en place à savoir la création de
postes la réforme des rythmes scolaires
et donc il est important que les
parlementaires puissent aussi des
cumulards est souvent des mères tous à
tous à tous puis 7 dans leur
circonscription d'ussel dans leur
circonscription pour voir comment se
passe par moi dans ma ville de dijon
la mise en place des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires puisque nous avons mis quatre
jours et demi n'a pas fière de crise on
aurait pu imaginer une session de crise
qui n'en voyaient que cette égalisation
de crise puisque quand on rentre le 9
septembre
ça veut dire que les commissions se
réunissent la semaine d'avant le
fonctionnement sais pas où je vais
apprendre le fonctionnement de
l'assemblée et du sénat
la reprise le 3 septembre en séance
plénière le 9
examen des textes dès le 3 on a beaucoup
essayé votre combat contre la limitation
du cumul des mandats est ce que vous
pensez que ce texte va arriver devant le
sénat avant la fin de la session de
l'été chien ce texte va être examiné au
mois de juillet par l'assemblée voté par
l'assemblée et devrait nous être
transmis fossé nous vers le mont doré
qui décident l'inscription septembre
pour la rentrée de septembre je pense ça
va avec la lourdeur du calendrier
l'ordre du jour en septembre ça va être
ça va être ça bien sûr on fait la
transparence nous en au mois de juillet
on a le texte sur la consommation donc
on n'arrête pas de travailler
est ce que vous pensez avoir sauvé
l'essentiel françois rebsamen en
renvoyant à la fin du quinquennat et
donc peut-être prendre après la fin du
quinquennat
l'application concrète de la fin du
cumul mais j'ai pas changé de position
les députés je pense que c'est juste
qu'ils aient une limitation du cumul je
sais qu'ils aiment pas juste ça mais
c'est comme ça je pense que nous on est
élu par des maires et qui n'est pas
normal j'ai toujours dit ça et donc je
vais voir ce qu'il va venir de
l'assemblée n'est pas normal quand on
est maire conclut sept sénateurs c'est
assez simple manuel valls prédit d'ores
et déjà des changements de comportement
des élus dès les prochaines élections
intermédiaires les municipales mais
aussi les régionales et départementales
parce qu'ils les élus vont anticiper sur
la lune et m'endors avec lui sûrement ça
va modifier profondément ça va rénover
moi j'aurais préféré parce que tes pieds
demandez quel mandat vous allez choisir
vous par exemple on est là aux
municipales à suivre du doigt production
ne suit pas dans la campagne des
municipales on va sans doute vous
demandez en 2017 vous allez choisir quoi
écoutez je vais choisir la vie des gens
puisque je suis candidat ils ne disent
on choisirait le sénat au mois de
septembre de l'année prochaine et après
je ferai mon choix
ouais vous confirmer à françois rebsamen
qu'il n'ya sans doute pas de congrès en
juillet et que la réforme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature ne veux pas
trouver la majorité des trois cinquièmes
je crois toujours ensemble je n'accepte
pas l'idée
je n'accepte pas l'idée que ici des
sénateurs que je considère comme des
bons sénateurs ump bon parce qu'ils ont
bien travaillé qui portait cette idée
républicaine de la réforme du csm
je pense à jean jacques hyest ou à
d'autres sénateurs centristes comme
zocchetto kg voter christiane taubira
était devant les centristes aujourd'hui
d'avoir une grosse visiblement les a pas
convaincus au pis si on va les mettre et
c'est le débat politique qui le fais au
sénat devant les contradictions comment
ont-ils pu voter cela il ya quatre ans
où il ya dix ans il refuse aujourd'hui
sinon pour des raisons politiciennes
je ne désespère pas que nous irait très
bien merci à vous merci françois
rebsamen
merci merci perrine bonsoir à tous et à
très vite